so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna make a
chatbot and we're just gonna do that
live coding style and what I've got here
is a terminal now this is my development
folder what I'm just gonna go ahead and
do is I'm gonna make a new directory and
the directory is gonna be called demo
demo demo demo or whatever like I have
many demo folders so this will be the
fifth one I've made but I'm just gonna
make a directory in here demo demo demo
there you go
and what I'm just gonna do is start a
new virtual environment in here now I'm
using Python three seven and what you
can then do from Python three seven and
I believe three six as well as you can
call the vient module directly and just
make a new virtual environment appear by
just using this part in one line of code
this will make a virtual environment and
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
install Raza inside of that virtual
environment
the downside is this Raza has a bunch of
dependencies including tensorflow
so installing might take a while but I
figured it would be a good idea that we
have this thing installing in the
background while I start explaining a
little bit about conversational
interfaces and what's tricky about them
and why an open source solution is
probably a good idea so I'm just gonna
source this virtual environment activate
it and let's do it the neat way with the
module thing and then I'll do Python pip
install Raza this should be the only
thing you need but this install can take
a while so just checking christian
kamilla so far I'm not going too fast I
hope I'm perfect so this stuff is
installing and we'll get back to it in a
bit but what I kind of want to talk
about are like we're gonna build a chat
bot from the command line it'll be the
end goal of this entire little workshop
but let's talk a little bit about chat
bolts in general so my name is Vincent
definitely ask me anything about chat
bots but what I am is I'm a research
advocate so it's my job to make sure
that whatever research we do at Raza
that people understand why we're doing
that research and also I do my best to
make sure that I even gel eyes
open source stack so what I'm gonna do
now is I'm just gonna talk to a chat bot
that's supposedly state-of-the-art so
what I've done here is I've opened up
the conve I from hugging face and
hugging face is an impressive company
and they're really doing some good work
but this is a state of the art chat pod
in a sense that it's doing everything
fully generative and I'm just gonna talk
to it and we'll see where it might fail
it's gonna be different failing than
what we saw with Siri though so you're
gonna type hello here and says hello how
are you doing and let's pretend that I'm
interested in buying a pizza good I want
to buy a pizza and then it says that
sounds good I'm a freelance accountant
and the thing is like if you think about
everything I was doing and the fact it
has to generate all of this text I mean
there's definitely something
state-of-the-art happening here
generating this grammatically correct
sentence is on its own
certainly not unimpressive but if I now
say Pizza hawai please don't let's start
saying that it is a free accountant and
it has OCD which is an original response
but this is not a system you want to put
in production that that's kind of the
thing it's it's a really cool demo but I
really want to have a chat bot that's
kind of constrained that says hey for
this one use case you're allowed to have
responses because in this case you know
it's talking about OCD and they're
really a fan of that but there's also a
risk that maybe the chat bot has learned
from a large corpus of reddit text and
it starts swearing which is also
something that you don't want to have in
production so even though this is still
definitely like a state-of-the-art
result this is not something that at
some point you're gonna go and put in
production and razza we kind of care
more about you know the theory and
articles are great but we want to have
chat bots that actually go ahead and
help people so that means that we
typically design our assistants with a
little bit of a constraint but one thing
I should point out first and foremost
and that's I'm assuming that a lot of
you are data scientists and a lot of you
are familiar with this system called
scikit-learn that's pretty much the the
get-go these days
and in a you know scikit-learn pipeline
life is relatively simple we've got this
X that we put into our system and then
at the end we get this prediction that
comes out and we can have all sorts of
like pre-processing steps in here and
machine learning models in here and
that's fine but one thing goes in and
one thing goes out we're making a
chatbot it's a little bit different
because we still have let's say one
thing going in we have a user here that
says I want to have pizza but then the
assistant in this case needs to detect
multiple things for starters we need to
say hey this uh pterence that indicates
a certain intent namely this user wants
to buy something but not only does that
user want to buy something the thing
that it wants to buy is a pizza so we
have to sometimes may be able to find
entities in the text that are relevant
for processing the message and then we
have to give it back an action and this
action sometimes has to be driven by
custom Python code so we are definitely
going to do machine learning and there's
definitely neural networks that are sort
of in the background of this but I do
hope that at the moment already you
recognize that we're really in a
different domain we are not in this
simple pipeline one thing goes in one
thing goes out but what Raza offers is
essentially a system where you can still
put in your own custom pipelines and
components here but Raza also offers the
framework to deal with all of this
around it and to give you a bit of an
example of that this is actually
somewhat involved I've got this one
example of a person trying to order a
pizza here so you know we've we've got
the user here and then we have the
digital assistant over here and a
theoretical conversation could be that
you say hello and then the first action
that this this assistant has to do is it
has to reply with hello back
after that the assistant has to listen
we have to not send anything back but
the action that we should do is we
should listen to the user to figure out
what to do next
then the user in this case could say hey
I'd like to buy a pizza and then the
digital assistant says oh what kind of
pizza what you like and what the user
that might do instead of actually
answering this question the user might
actually throw some sort of an
interruption that says oh yeah by the
way are you a human or are you a digital
assistant and then it will be nice if
the chat bot was able to say well first
I'm going to answer your question then
I'm going to pick up the conversation
where we left it and then I'm gonna go
ahead and listen again to what the user
has to say and this whole system all the
machine learning you need for this razza
is a nice open-source tool to handle
this situation but that's sort of what
we offer but what I hope that you
recognize is that we don't have the same
pipeline anymore and also we're training
the system for a sequence of tasks it's
not just text goes in and a single
action comes out as you see in this
example the sequence of actions that
have happened so far they really matter
so that so I hope you also agree that
we're not gonna start this research by
loading in a CSV file I mean that's not
gonna work for our use case here we need
to have some sort of a data format
that's a little bit more than just see
his feet so we're gonna start a new
Rossum project in a moment but there's a
couple of files that Arase projects
should have the data for this project is
typically stored in markdown files and
it might be a little bit
counterintuitive to what you're used to
because it's not really common to do
machine learning or markdown files but
the idea is that markdown gives us sort
of a domain-specific language to declare
conversations and that's typically quite
useful so in this example I have my
annal unit MD file here and NLU stands
for natural language understanding and
the idea is that we can specify a
certain intent so right now I've got the
intent for a greeting and then under
that I have a list of examples that fit
that specific intent and what's nice is
that this file will eventually get into
git and it will be easy for people to
add examples to certain intense or add
an intent but we basically say here
intent examples intent examples that
that's the way that we're gonna define
the understanding but having just an
intent is typically not enough because
we saw the example before that we have
this order that we have to keep in mind
and you can definitely assume that you
know saying goodbye usually happens
after saying hello and not vice versa so
yes we have this part of the data but we
also have are these stories and the idea
is that if this intent is like a Lego
brick then a story is where you can
click these Lego bricks together to fill
sort of two constructs a conversation
that could have happened in the past so
for example we have this happy path over
here where somebody says hey hello the
robot says back hello
otter greet and then the user says I'm
happy and then the robot says okay I
hear that you're happy there's a example
of a story that's a conversation that
could have happened so if I can ask
greed and know that's a really good
question by the way mood Greed's is the
intent
after happy is the action from the
assistant so we have some definition of
an action that should happen over here
and the idea is that the training data
that we're generating to some extent
there's a machine learning model that
will detect ah given this intent this is
probably the best action that we're
interested in but there's also a
different model that will sort of handle
the fact that we're moving a long time
here as well I'm not going to go too
much in detail because this is meant as
a more of an introduction thing but
mapping this text
to the correct intent we typically refer
to that as a classifier but given a
sequence of intents and responses what's
the next best action now we call that a
policy and as a different machine
learning model so to say but for the
question is to detail but an intent if
it happens later in the story can
trigger a different response technically
yes so you're right there technically
you are completely correct so one
example I have I have one example of
this is something I made a demo for
today actually it was part of my job so
let's say I have a chat bot that has a
countdown so the user says I want you to
count and then the first response is 10
and then the user says ok and then the
next response should be a 9 and then the
user again says okay and the next
response should be an 8 right that's
something that could happen but now if
the user were to say are you a bot then
the correct response here would be to
say yes and then a 7 and if I were to
ask are you a both here then I should
get yes and then a 6 so this context is
handled by the policy system so to say
but definitely I hope you also agree
that depending on what happened in the
beginning of the conversation at the end
of the conversation I might need to give
a different answer as well
but the trouser does have mechanisms in
place to deal with this a good question
by the way um another thing that's
useful to mention I suppose is we see a
nice example of that here we it might be
the case that we have a certain intent
and then we have to say oh here's two
actions in sequential that have to
follow and that's also a put an option
here it doesn't just have to be we say
one thing it can also be here's like two
actions and sequential and also after
after we've just done this action we
should always listen until the user says
something back so listening is also an
active actions that I say
anyway back to the main topic we have
these intents and we see that these
intents are used as stories but that
means that we have one last Lego brick
to deal with and that is what about
these actions we have to define those as
well and typically those are stored in
this domain but Yemma file and that's
just a configuration file where you can
say hey here's all of my intents and
you're also able to say and here's all
these actions and responses typically a
lot of these responses can be simple for
example just say a little bit of text if
you're making a frequently asked
questions chatbot then usually just
sending some text back can be fine
but we are also able to add actions in
here that are just Python code so then
you can customize whatever response you
would like an action could be some
Python code that fetches some
information from a database etc but we
have to declare our intents and our
responses and also some entities in this
domain at yellow file that's what that
config file is for
there's one final configuration file and
that is aptly named config tamil and the
idea behind that file is that that is
where you define your machine learning
pipeline now we have a yellow file here
because we think that's convenient
but in the back all the code that you
see here is just Python that's running
you know some tensorflow code and in the
case of this count vectorizer that Sai
could learn but you can also add your
own custom Python code in here if you
want to experiment with your own methods
that's completely possible but these are
typically - for files that you have to
specify in order to get a chatbot
running and I hope that given the
examples that I've shown you that it's
plausible that we need more than there's
a CSV file we need these settings files
in order to get started a benefit of
this is that we don't necessarily have
to write a whole bunch of custom Python
code to get started because these four
files on their own will be able to cover
a lot of ground for us so just a
reminder we have four files that are
disposal that we have to use the config
that llamó file machine learning stuff
domain that yem oh that's the overview
of all the intents and the responses and
custom actions the stories are examples
of LEGO bricks click together that
represent conversations that could have
happened in the past and the day of the
NLU file that has all sorts of examples
of intents and entities that are meant
to sort of give training data towards a
intent
you
so just to quickly check
Christiaan any questions on this
anything unclear and I was wondering if
you um intent detection is a
classification problem you teach by
example in that case you need to provide
enough examples to detect this
particular intent is that right so
you're completely right there the
question is I it is hard for me to know
when I've given you enough data and in
general at least in practice I can make
this argument let's say that this is all
the data that we train on and it means
that those are all the examples we've
given to our system and let's say that
these are all the conversations that
users actually end up having with our
chat BOTS and there's the the main
problem I think in production is that
you usually come up with paths and
stories that you think users are gonna
have then when you put it into
production you realize actual users
actually behave a little bit differently
but you are completely correct in the
sense that it helps if you have this
panel you file that you definitely
supply with more examples note though
that we do have word embeddings at our
disposal as well and the way the way to
improve is provide examples there's
nothing about syntax or keywords or you
just well I mean there's also this
notion of conversational design right so
you as a programmer get to decide when
am I gonna use entities when are intense
enough and how our user supposed to
interact so I don't want to discount the
fact that conversational design
definitely matters here but in general
you're certainly correct the more valid
examples that you have of training data
the better the only thing and we'll see
that in a moment is that it is a good
idea to come up with training data that
covers a lot of ground I can come up
with 10 examples which are all
variations of spelling for the word
hello but it would also be good to say
greetings and hat you know come up with
a little bit of ground covering data set
so to say so the ideal case would be
your examples are everything that could
be said
everything every way that this could be
for me in terms of machine learning
training performance I would argue yes
but it's not gonna happen in reality and
also I mean we should also be aware that
the more data we give this thing
training times are gonna increase and we
will get a limit there at some point as
well and we can use GPUs of Rous I mean
all that stuff works but in practice my
advice is to give this to users as
quickly as possible because in my
experience so far no chatbot goes as
planned in the sense that you cannot
predict what people give to these
chatbots some pure gibberish in practice
how long do these files need to be how
many examples do you need until you see
some good results what what might be
better in that sense is how about we
just make a chatbot right now well just
start locally and my goal will be to
fool the chat BOTS we're gonna see if we
can break it and we'll find out it's
relatively easy but but it will but one
thing I have to warn you for it is a bit
of a cat-and-mouse game and that's
mainly because I don't know exactly how
my users are gonna end up using my app
and if the distribution of stuff I get
in production is different than what I
have in training and you're gonna be in
a tough spot and I would argue that
that's probably the main concern there
is a question here in the chat how does
any human human of conversations as
reinforcement modify any config or
domain or override it this is a question
that's in the chat as well so can i
where's that button it's normally on
your thought oh wait I think yes I'm
using two screens here and I think I can
click more and then chat and okay but
it's fun it's grand
how does actual human human conversation
has been forcefully modify and configure
the man so we don't actually the the
idea is because we have this idea of a
story we do constrain the algorithm a
little bit because we can say these are
all the intents that you're able to
detect and also these are the only
responses you're able to give back so
we're not using actual human to human
conversations here now there are systems
that do that and the hugging face system
that I showed you earlier something in
that realm but for now I think the state
yard is not in the position where I
would comfortably put something like
that in production the main reason being
if your corpus has swear words in it or
chatbots kind of swearing and typically
when you put something in production you
constrain the artificial stupidity more
than you want immediately optimize all
the artificial intelligence you've
learned from Microsoft a that that is a
industry reference yes there's another
example which I thought was interesting
you can google the photo it's pretty
funny so I think this was a photo taker
and from the earliest chat BOTS at
PayPal and then a chat bot says hey I'm
still learning but you can ask me
anything and I'll try to help you
and then the person replies by saying oh
I got scammed and then the above reply
great
which you know is some ideal response
but that totally there's a photo of that
mmm but again let's very quickly just go
into this demo because I think it's
gonna give a couple of nice examples -
so we've just done rasa installed rasa
and one nice thing is that that gives us
the rasa Camaro blank app now this one
outside currently and we're trying to
fix this if you try to get like the help
from rasa here it's gonna be a little
slow because there's all sorts of
tensorflow libraries that have to run in
the backend of it so instead of doing
the help of showing you everything
command line can do how about I just run
the init command and what this command
is gonna do is it's gonna initialize the
project
so that means that we're just gonna get
a clean starter kit to play with now
again this is gonna be a little bit slow
as still tension flow has to be imported
and loaded and all of that stuff but I
think in a couple of seconds we should
see something of a prompt that says oh
you want to start a project select the
folder - you're interested in yep there
we go let's make this just a little bit
bigger
depends on what like I think most people
should see at least something like this
just checking people are noting but I
think it's fine so you have to give her
the path where the project will be
created and I think the current
directory is fine because again I'm
doing this in the demo demo demo folder
it's asking it's not empty is it fine I
think it is so I'll just say yes
and the next thing that it's asking me
is if I want to train an initial model
and I do so what's happened now is a
bunch of files appeared and we're now
also going to say use those files to
train an actual chat bot it's gonna be
super basic but we're just gonna go
ahead and train this and what you should
see now is you should if you if you used
to care us you should see some things
that you might be familiar with like
this epoch thing you might have seen
that before if you're using Karis but
essentially here you're seeing that
we're training a bunch of systems
okay so some more stuff is training does
a GPU come in handy so I the thing is
probably it's just like enough I've
never really needed the GPU myself and I
will say that that's a benefit but like
my I have colleagues in the research
team who do use their GPU the thing is
that we are currently trying to figure
out what's the best way to benchmark all
with this because there are parts
because there's bottlenecks etc it's a
bit of a detail but do you there are
speed ups that you can achieve using GPU
most of the stuff that we're using is
based off of transformers so we're not
using LS CMS as much anymore in our
stack so that seems that the improvement
that you should be able to get our
should be reasonable anyway you should
now see something like this where hey
yeah we've trained an assistant on the
command line so we could go ahead and
sort of start talking to it so I'm gonna
start talking to it and everyone's
allowed to sort of do the same thing
I'll zoom in just a little bit okay so
this is the demo of a very very basic
chat bot but what I am able to do now is
I'm able to say hello it's asking me hey
how are you I can say I am sad and then
it's telling me that there's something
to cheer me up so let's let's put that
mysterious link in a browser and see
what happens well it's a cute picture of
a cat so that's always nice did that
help you I can say no and then the chat
bot says goodbye again I'm what's I'm
not suggesting that is the best
assistant ever but this is the basic
demo now yeah so I think we have a
little bit we have enough time for that
so this is the basic thing it just got
running so what I'm just gonna go ahead
and do now is I'm gonna ctrl C out of
this and I'm going to just open this
folder up in visual coach studio and
there is this nifty little shorthand
command that you can type called code
which will open up the app but you can
also just point to the folder and I'm
just gonna work from here for now
because from visual studio code I also
have this terminal
my disposal now you can just source the
virtual environment here and then this
will be a good place for me to play
around and then demo some stuff I
suppose so what are we gonna go ahead
and do is I'm gonna go to this data
folder and I'm gonna open the NLU 2 MB
file and you should recognize a few
things like we have this intent greet
which is detecting the greeting for
example and we also have this intent
goodbye as well as a firm of an eye a
mood great and the mood unhappy and
these are all in here and there's also
an intent for challenging whether or not
you are a bot which is a really good
intent to actually implement but but
these are sort of the intense and I hope
we recognize that from the slides I
showed you earlier we can also see that
there are some stories and again we see
that there's the greeting which again is
the fine over here and then we have a
greeting we have a response we have the
mood great we have the response and
there's a couple of paths here now
there's also this domain a yellow file
let's just quickly have a look at that
and we see a list of all the intents but
the main thing at least to us is we also
see these responses so utter greets for
example that's actually listed in here
and there's the utter cheer up where we
get some text as well as an image and so
I hope we recognize some of the separate
parts that we've talked about earlier
and what we can also see here is that we
have this config dot yellow file and
again these are all these settings for
the machine learning stuff that we're
running we're not gonna really change
this as much but I figured it'd be good
to point out that these are here and you
can also point to your own custom Python
classes from here that's also totally
possible what I'm not gonna go ahead and
do is I am just gonna go ahead and type
rasa shell what rasa shelled am I going
too fast by the way just
because we have these files but now I
want to show you hey let's see the robot
fail and then we'll see if he can fix it
so in particular what I would like to do
now is I'll type the rasa shell and rasa
shell is just gonna give us the
interface that we had before so nothing
new per se takes a while let's get
started but once it's there yes
so I can type hello here and we get the
hey how are you and I call it a type hi
and I can also say yo and I'm gonna I
would argue that this is a very clear
failure alright so I type yo and it
thinks that I have to say goodbye and
the question kind of is well why is that
all for starters
yo is not listed here as one of the
possible intents so there you kind of go
it's probably this count factor that
hasn't recognized and also what we're
doing here is we are so far only using
if you look at the config file
the only real features that we're using
here are count vectors so we're not
using word embeddings or anything like
that
yo probably would have been picked up
correctly if we're using word embeddings
but we're not just one question at this
point yeah does it always output an
intent or is there a kind of a default
or failure mode if it doesn't clearly
detect there are settings that you can
tweak for this and all um so there's two
ways of dealing with this we give you
the option of saying hey well first of
all let's have an intense for out of
scope that's one thing that we can do
and it's actually not the worst idea so
suppose you have a chat bot for pizzas
if someone starts talking about fire
hydrants that would be an excellent
opportunity to say hey let's fall back
so you can have the fall back intent
that's one thing that you can do the
other thing that you can do is we have
this idea like all these models they
have some sort of probability that they
output some confidence level it always
sums up to one and we have this fallback
policy where we can say if the
difference between the top two
if the difference between that
probability is really slim okay we need
to fall back and ask the user to sort of
repeats themselves because that way we
might get a sentence that's easier to
detect so then I was wondering where the
buy comes from when you type in you like
does it automatically go to the most
probable class or does it go to the
goodbye intent automatically so let's
have a look at that because what I can
do is I can also type rasa shell and all
you and that's gonna give us a little
bit more insight and what the model
output is and we're just we're just
gonna investigate this for now because I
I agree with your curiosity now one
thing about this mlu is that this is
going to completely forgo the order in
which the conversation happens these are
just the classifiers for the intents and
the entities that we're going to be
looking at but for debugging purposes we
are going to get more information so
let's start by saying hello again and
now we get this big Jason thing we can
stare into and what you can see here is
that yeah definitely greet that's that's
the most the highest one but now let's
say yo didn't just see what happens yeah
so it's definitely confused here and if
I if I were able to hypothesize what is
going wrong here we are using count
vectorizer x' and we're looking at
character engrams as well and if I think
of the word yo right this is a y in
there and then always well so I can
imagine it eventually probablistic ly
that's the reason why we're seeing this
so what's the most probable class oh
yeah that's that's certainly true and
the one thing that would be nice now
though isn't and that's something you
know if you see this in production you
would label this and what we can do now
is we can just add the word yo here and
the nice thing about this is this gave
us an opportunity to call rasa train
once again and and at this point you
know this is a really minor change but
one thing that I do think is kind of
nice about this
tax is know towered sort of looking at
this file as if it's a config file and
if you think about machine learning
pipelines I didn't think there's
something elegant about your data
actually being a config file as
something that you actively maintain as
such so in that sense it's it might be
uncommon to write your data in this
format but I hope that we also recognize
that Mary love it
now one thing that just happens because
we just retrained the new model if you
pop open this models folder you will
notice that there's a new file here with
a date/time stamp in the name and that's
because we just trained the new model
and every time you call rasa shell well
we are doing internally is just grabbing
the most recent one but you can also
select a flag that says open up another
one but note that this tar over here you
can upload this and set that into
production this is just everything that
we've trained and zipped but now if we
go to the router shell and we do the
whole yo thing again then we should see
an improvement okay so I'll do yo now
and it's now being detected correctly
and again this is a little bit cheating
of course because the example is
literally in the training data at this
point in time but I hope that people
recognize like oh yeah we just trained a
new model of the new model appeared in
this models folder and that's picked up
by Raza failure so what I'm hoping is
that at this phase people recognize that
if they want to add an intent or more
examples that they have a feeling on how
to do that I mean sure we haven't shown
you two steps yet but if you want to add
examples you just add another row here
in this and all you dub MD file if you
want to add an intense we can just copy
this and give it a new name here and
fill in these examples well we don't
have to do is we have to add a story
here and then we have to make sure it's
in this domain at Gemmell and what I
could do now
I could do it a demo where I take all of
those steps and I showed them to you but
I think that you know that these are not
the hardest things to do and I imagine
and at least I imagined that were a
little bit more interested in seeing how
entities work and how we can get our
custom Python code running as well so
what I would propose we do now is just
half the little break like a couple of
minutes and then what I'll do is I'll
share a git repository with you
that contains a pokeymon chat bot that I
am building that is meant as an open
source example but that has a custom
Python component in it and it also has
examples of entities that we can go
ahead and play with as well very good
do we need to know anything about
Pokemon to follow or just barely if for
all intents and purposes we all agree
it's some Japanese kids show that's five
years like I'm not the biggest Pokemon
expert I get corrected all the time on
Twitter like all the time but first I
just want to make sure that the people's
questions are answered at this phase I
think this is a nice little milestone in
that sense so give me all your questions
and if you want to grab a glass of water
go ahead and someone says pika pika and
that's okay okay and pokemons go that's
good to know
so there was a question by prom night is
there a way to programmatically copulate
in tents there yes
so definitely then there's even packages
that do this I I I do want to mention
that you might want to be just a little
bit careful there so the idea is that
you might be able to say well it's full
on I'm gonna come up with all sorts of
questions about Pokemon so you can
imagine I have what pokemon has this
type and then the type is something I
can loop over maybe I can replace the
word wats with which and I can generate
all sorts of training examples there the
analogy here is that this is reasonably
similar to deep learning and images
where I take an image of someone's face
and you rotate that the idea behind it
is okay but if it's one person's image
and just rotating it 10,000 times we
shouldn't think that that's 10,000 data
points and and with that in mind it
might actually be a better idea to just
sit down with a bunch of people and
actually grab a thesaurus to make sure
you're covering a lot of ground instead
of just repeating the same data over and
over again that's a risk that we have
seen as clients one thing that's
interesting about this particular
problem is that one of our researchers
actively working on this we are trying
to figure out if we can come up with
generative algorithms where you give us
five sentences and we'll generate twenty
that are similar you can select three
did you like those are now all in the
generative parts and then we generate
more of them and we think that that
might actually be a pretty valid use
case for generative algorithms because
we're using that to generate training
data that you yourself still label this
is an active research project but if
people are interested we do have collab
notebooks where people can try this out
themselves as you might have noticed
we're a pretty open company when it
comes to research
many more questions in a chart please
Camila this is there was just one
question now when talking about entities
is it mandatory to be taxed or it can be
numbers for example I create story that
asked how many tickets and user answers
integral three instead words how has a
solve this problem it's from Murali yeah
now so we have tools for that so a
couple of ways we have this I think it's
called duckling if I'm not mistaking so
we have this duckling entity extractor
and duckling is just there's a bunch of
heuristics in there and they're really
good for getting like numbers and
monetary amounts and then that sort of
thing so if you want to fetch all the
dollars out that's why I'm way of doing
it and you can also select entities by
giving us a red X that's also something
that we can use that it's X enemies and
recently this is a feature that we
released I think three weeks ago maybe
two we are now also making roles and
groups for entities so you can say hey
this is the first dollar amount in this
utterance and this is the second dollar
amount that I've seen the idea here
being if suppose you're making a chaplet
for an airline then you have two cities
but one of them is a destination and the
other one is where your is the origin so
the entities that we train for can also
have that context attached as well this
is a new feature
I should add to that but definitely if
you're more interested in just getting
numbers out we have some you have some
components that are specialized towards
doing just that
so what I'm not gonna do is go to github
and I think github slash rasa HQ is what
you're gonna want to have and then CR
opens projects here but there's like
rasa rasa del Rosso SDK there's a bunch
of them what you cannot type in here
though is pokedex
and I think if you type in pokedex -
demo browser into Google you should also
get here then but just to reiterate get
up calm slash rasa HQ and then there is
this pokedex demo that you can find and
well I'm just gonna go ahead and do is
I'm gonna clone this a cheesy HTTP but
for my co-pilot you probably want this
with SSH instead because it will be nice
you can make a merge request in a bit
and what I'm just gonna go ahead and do
what's used those to do cut for that go
back here I'm just gonna go ahead and do
is I'm just gonna do the quick and dirty
thing I was gonna make you're gonna
clone rectly in this folder here and it
might be better to move that to a
separate repo that's that's definitely
valid but I'm just gonna make the
Pokedex demo pair in the folder I felt
over here and any reason for is I then
have access to the virtual environments
but you can definitely put this in a
Perl or fuller as well nice and what I'm
then gonna go ahead and do gonna open
the Pokedex demo in a new window for
Visual Studio code not save anything
they've done here
and what you should see is some it looks
really similar to the rasa init program
it's just that here we have different
examples in our NLU dat MD file and
there's also this Pokemon db2 JSON file
over here but this is in all intents and
purposes still more similar to Raza and
NIT than than anything else
but one of the things that you're going
to notice here is that there's a couple
of different intents in particular
there's one here called demand joke so
one of the features that I've made is
I've made this intent where the user
says that they want to learn hey they
want to hear a Pokemon based joke so
that's an intent that I have added and
you'll notice that I've actually come up
with a bunch of ways to ask for a joke
here another thing that I've done below
here is I've got this intent but there's
also some entities here so for example I
could have an intense where I'm asking
the chat BOTS could you confirm if this
pokemons name exists that's technically
exactly what the Pokedex is supposed to
do so you can say hey is Bulbasaur a
Pokemon and in this case with this
syntax we're saying bill bazaar this
string that is an entity of type Pokemon
name but the name of the Pokemon so to
say and in this particular case because
there's lots and lots of these Pokemon
I'm probably not gonna have an example
for each and every single one of them so
we have these utilities like a lookup
table so in this particular case I can
say hey here's all the pokemons names
and then Raza is able to figure out
alright so then I can replace whatever
pokemons name is listed in here and I
can put it there generate some data and
that way I don't have to come up with a
every single Pokemon that I have and and
the reason why I like showing this is
Raza has a couple of these utilities so
to say they kind of make it easier for
you to declare a whole bunch of these
entities so you can also come up with
things like synonyms so you can say NYC
instead of New York City and that's also
something that you can declare this DLS
dsl star the same to occur it still
needs to train with all of these
generated examples it's just a way of
automating the creation of training data
like yeah that's it's it's it's just so
that you as a developer have less
cognitive load on this yes and also the
way that we generate these training
examples is we look at this story
then we say oh we had a greeting here
okay we're gonna grab a greeting okay
this one and then we're had a we had an
action and then we're gonna take another
example of this and that's how this
training data is generated on your
behalf but we automate that such that
you don't really have to bother with
that that much but you can see here that
definitely I have some more intense and
I even have an entity here at the bottom
so that that's that's something that
that's relatively exciting so let's have
a so we've had a look at this an alert
and B file so the next thing that you
might want to have a peek at are these
stories but the stories files not
particularly interesting the main thing
that is interesting is that we are using
our new demand joke over here and we're
saying hey let's uh turret joke and then
we say over here that we have a confirm
exists intent that is followed by an
action check existence and one thing
that is interesting is that action here
it starts with the word action instead
of the word utter so it isn't a
different type of action in that sense
it has a different name and there's a
reason for it if you want to discover
the reason why part of that can be found
in this domain that yellow file yeah
we've all of our actions and again we
see that one action sort of stands out
let's check existence one we also see
that the intents are definitely in here
we see that the entities is also listed
here so we've got this entity that the
main files now also aware of but then if
we look at the responses greeting
cheering-up we have a lots of jokes and
our disposal here but the one thing
that's not in here is this action check
existence that's the one thing that we
don't have and that is because this is a
custom action we need custom Python code
to be able to handle that and that also
means that we cannot just have some text
that we utter we actually have to write
that down in a file somewhere and if you
were now to you know check that later
but if you were now to go to actions
that PI you will see a Python file
that has a class implemented and this
this class is called action check
existence and it inherits from the
action class that comes from the Raza
software development kit and in
particular this class has a method
called name and the name of this action
is action check existence so this is how
you make the link to the domain file
that this is indeed a custom Python code
that's supposed to run and there's one
method in particular that where all the
logic essentially gets handled and it's
we might get into the details of this at
the end but the main thing that's
important is that we can we can and we
have access to this tracker and this
tracker has all every everything that
happened in the conversation so far and
in particular it has this one object
called latest message which is a
dictionary that has all sorts of
information and in particular it can
grab the entities out for us and what I
can then do is I can say if that entity
type is pokemons name what I can then do
is I can check hey have I seen that name
before
in this pokemons the txt file if I have
well then I can say yes it's a Pokemon
and if I haven't and I can say I don't
recognize the name and in this case I'm
just reading it in from a file but in
practice you can imagine you would read
in from a database here so it's quite
straightforward code right it doesn't
check and all puts the message so I
definitely have a world yeah do you do
complex stuff in these actions like
update some state so the thing is you
could and one and there's one use case
for example so and suppose I have the
pizza-delivery chat bot thing so we have
this notion of entities right those are
sort of things that we can detect but
maybe some of these entities are
long-lived
like your address for example is that's
I don't want to get that from the last
message that's something that's
to be long-lived so you can imagine that
if currently I don't have your address
yet I might first check the database if
I have it and if I have it there then I
can fill in this thing called a slot and
the slot in Raza is like an entity but
it's long lived so so that could be a
use case so to say but the goal of this
is in this custom code so that means
that you have the freedom to do whatever
you think you might need want to scrape
a website you can so what you don't do
is write your own state machine maintain
everything but you use the tools that
rather provides like I mean there's
custom Python code so if you want to go
ahead and do that I'm not going to be
able to stop you but I will gently urge
you that there is a better way of going
with so so state machines I get where
the idea came from right but it's
eventually it's harder to maintain
that's sort of the idea behind this and
the nice thing about these stories is
that you know you can strain the chap
out a nice way you can actually say oh
this is a story that I assume happens
and yeah I guess you can see some things
like a state machine in here but I have
found it to be an unusual reference
there is a lot of literature on it
though so I get the reference but it's I
have found it it gets in the way
mentally the better way to think about
is hey a user has this intent now given
this intent what's the next best action
that's a good yeah it's it's kind of a
UI thing I would argue almost for
developers but but really good question
well I hope people recognize from this
though unless there's other questions
something about the clarity of grammar
and it feels a little bit off topic so
I'll ignore that one for now but but
what I think might be interesting for us
to do is let's just run this custom
action with a chat bot so far I think it
might be a cool thing to do so
well quickly
now is all we'll need to start up two
things actually
so I'll get the terminal here and what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna start another
terminal on the side as well so I've got
these two terminals at my disposal now I
will source the virtual environment
first and foremost oops
source them in oh wait those in the
folder right this is kind of annoying
because the virtual environment is in
the folder in the parent folder okay
I've got I've got my virtual
environments here so that's good and
what I'm gonna do first is just call
Raza train from here because I need that
model well there's a second thing that I
need to do as well and that has to do
with how Raza works so you can imagine
that I have my natural language
understanding part of Raza
right so that's but something of Raza
offers and then text goes in and then we
we try to give you the right action to
follow but then if we have our own
custom actions right the question then
is in production do we want to have
those actions inside of this NLU or
should we maybe consider that as a
separate service now if I'm gonna run
this in a docker container should these
two live in the same container and in
production we found out that just
there's a lot of engineering reasons why
I want to separate the two so that means
that you have typically this NLU service
running that will handle the you know
the state of the user as well as what's
the current action etc but then if a
custom action needs to be called then we
have this action service that we have to
call and that has benefits because we
can look at these logs separately and
kind of in the micro service style of
thinking we do want to have a separate
box for this guy and that means that if
I want to now you know play with these
actions I should run my own action
server to keep all that stuff simple
though what you can just go ahead and do
is you can type browser run actions and
it will just pick up this action
file and start a server locally for you
if you want to do is more formally we
could package it up as a docker
container and open up the right port but
for now this will just be easier so what
I'm gonna do is in this terminal I'm
gonna run browser run actions and that's
gonna start a servers a service and I'm
gonna type as a shell in this one and
that's going to give us the old shell
that we're used to and it should be able
to pick up though that we have an action
server running there's a config file
that I've set in this project for that
this takes a while to start up
but the bots should now be loaded what
I'll do is I'll just grab this and all
you file so we have this example here
and what I should be able to do now is I
could say hey just hi how are you say
give me a joke
why did it squirrel across the road to
get to the other tide
well not the good another super good
joke but okay the feature works but now
what I can do is I can say is though
thus our pokemons that's a question I
can ask and we see that something over
here happened and it's saying here yes
Bulbasaur is a Pokemon so we can see
that we have the natural language
understanding saying hey a certain
action needs to be triggered that
message is passed to the action service
and then we get a response back here and
we see that we're also printing some
extra information here any extra
information that we're printing here by
the way and that's information you have
access to is all the confidences for all
these different intents they're passed
with the message that you get into the
action server as well so this is a lot
to suddenly see but I hope that we from
a know if we take a step back the main
thing that's just happened is we have
this custom action over here that is
able to trigger Python code that's
basically what's happened and we give
this message back by accessing this
dispatcher and we're saying hey just
send text back we can also send images I
mean that's also something that we can
send this way we depending on what
platform we are launching this on we can
also send buttons and then all sorts of
forms etc but we do have custom Python
code handling some logic for us and I
can do something like is boo Babar a
Pokemon and it's still not perfect
because in this case it's unfortunately
detected that we want to have a joke
right so we still need to add examples
this this Chapel is not perfect but I
think if I have the example is nine
tails
right then we trigger the action server
again because this is misspelled they
show again the command that we need to
run the actions yes
sorry if I'm sorry I went too fast razza
run actions and that command will assume
that your custom Python code is in an
actions the PI file so that that's the
one assumption that that thing makes but
this should start the action server
locally so those that are interested
there is this extra yellow file that
I've not really discussed but it's
called endpoints that yamo and you can
specify hey the action endpoint that I
have for this that's over here so that's
because and that's how it's able to find
the action server it's basically
something that you can configure I'm
currently running some experiments to
see if we can also run the action server
in a cloud function that's something
that you could potentially also do here
but in production this would basically
points to a docker container somewhere
it's definitely not perfect but but I do
hope that we see like how the separate
parts work together any quick questions
on this
also from the chat Mary
guys are you still with us okay I just
yeah we have some yes yeah yes we have
some years on the chat people listen
maybe you can explain to me what's
happening so I typed in the only thing I
know the answer is Picasso a Pokemon and
the answer was I do not recognize
Pikachu are you sure this correctly I'm
not sure Pikachu is spelled with a k did
you spelled this way yeah this is how
you spelled it or you spelled
differently okay so you type is Pikachu
a Pokemon like this with a question mark
and pika
yeah so I think it's the capitalization
of Pikachu because it's really good but
if the action function that's doing a
bit of a mess up I think one way to fix
that I think is if I look at the entity
yeah so I should called up lower there I
think that's the the fix or maybe put it
into pre-processing could your car what
do you mean by that exactly I mean if
you want to ignore capitalization in
general could you define it somewhere
the pre process is everything in this
case I would argue all users are able to
capitalize stuff to you right so that's
something that you should be a little
bit mindful of technically what you can
definitely do is write your own
tokenizer that makes everything
lowercase actually come to think of it I
think that's actually a setting of the
white cat white space tokenizer I think
you're able to say hey I want you all
the tokens to be lowercase I would maybe
not do that because you do lose
information that way but you can if you
want to okay I think this is still a
pretty good practice though
we've got some questions in the chat
mm-hmm is Rosa a Pokemon why there's no
trigger
so let's there's a wall so there's a
couple of things happening here in the
background so what I'm going to do now
is I'm going to hypothesize what is
happening here but it's there's because
there's multiple parts I cannot suggest
that I'm 100% accurate here so it's
saying here I absolutely love Pokemon so
then the question is what action was
triggered and if I go to my domain but
Yama file I think this is a joke
in fact I'm sure it's a joke it's listed
here and the reason why it's a joke is
because absol is a Pokemon this this
joke in particular was a PR from New
Zealand I can can I remember that so the
thing that happened here was other joke
was sort of mentioned here so then the
question is okay how can that be well
I'm using the word Pokemon here and I
can imagine that the word Pokemon also
appears if I go to the NLU file over
here so the word Pokemon does make a
couple of appearances in this intent
over here and you know I have three
examples over here with Demand joke and
I only have one example here and so that
already is kind of a thing that can go
wrong especially if you further consider
that it's not just the word that I'm
detecting it's not just a count vector
for that word it's also for all the
little combinations of characters inside
of it as well and I'm also generating
lots and lots and lots of features so my
guess is is that that is where something
is going wrong and the easiest way to
fix that is just make sure that I've got
more examples over here this feels like
a data problem I would say
now one thing I suppose it is
interesting I what I can do here is I
can say is Raza Kokomo named a Pokemon
name that exists now I can I'd this
example and in this particular case what
is interesting is that Raza does not
exist as a Pokemon name but in the
context of this sentence I might be able
to argue that this token over here needs
to be picked up and checked by our
action as if it is a pokemons name so in
that sense I still want this to be
detected as the entity even though it
doesn't exist as an actual Pokemon name
that's also something for this
particular use case I suppose to
consider incredible hypothesis thank you
so at this point in time there's a
couple of things that I think might be
interesting or fun to do so one thing
that we could that the one thing that is
valid I think at this point is let's add
some data and it can be like a nice PR
that's something that we can do but if
we're gonna add more data I think I want
to show you a good habit you got a
definitely we can add like yo here right
I mean that's something that we could -
but when I think about Raza and ways
that me and the research team can help
some of you folks sure we make
algorithms but some of the things that
we're also now open sourcing are data
sets and I just want to highlight that
because I do think that's probably the
most valid way to get started so if you
go to Raza HQ and I think if you do like
NLU yes so if you if you in github type
Enel you in the repository search you
will find this NLU - training data
repository and the idea behind this
repository is is that we want to
crowdsource some datasets such that you
have an easier time coming up with good
models so we have some common things
that people in banking like to use we
have some custom scripts that will
remove entities and that's something
you're worried about but in our
particular case we also have this small
talk
file and I'll just open up the raw file
and we just have a couple of examples
listed here that you can just go ahead
and copy and paste and this is something
that's also a community project this is
something that we're actively building
but we do think and we seriously think
that having a good data set to start
with is probably your primary concern in
the beginning you know we can have very
fancy transformer architectures etc but
if the data set is not representative of
something that users are actually going
to type then you know you're gonna be in
a bad spot by your way so if you're
gonna get started with the chatbots
remember that we have these repositories
with datasets you can copy and paste
from so that's the first sort of hint
and tippet I might want to give you and
there's actually a second hint I think I
should be giving as well and to do that
what I will need to do is share this
browser tab because so far I think I've
given like the hello world like I've
shown you the features of razza etc but
I haven't really talked about yet is how
do you actually do this stuff in
practice because you know there's this
deployment story but there's also this
data quality issue that I think is at
the center of all of this and for that I
just want to show you this other
products that we've made called rasa X
and the idea behind Rose X it's free so
you can go ahead and download it and use
it but it's not open source because we
don't want Amazon to host this on behalf
of themselves we are more than happy
that you host this for your chat box but
we're less happy if you're gonna host
this product and charge other people
money for it but if you're using your
own chat pod you can go ahead and stalls
on the VM and what this essentially is
is a user interface on top of all the
files that I have shown you and we have
you know some sentence that was spoken
and then we can say hey is this the
prayer crew I predicted correctly and I
can say yes or no and this is sort of a
labeling tool that we can use for that
there's a nice little train button here
so I can retrain all of this stuff and
in particular the coolest feature and I
think that's also something I would like
to remind everyone this is why you want
to install
razza X is I have this button over here
that allows me to share this chat box
with other people so I can say something
like demo people please play around and
this will then generate a link for me
and I apologize it's an HTTP link North
HTTP but this allows me to give to you a
link to a chat bot made live rasa
everyone in the meeting and you should
be able to interact with that so if I go
to this other browser window here
assuming nothing is going wrong because
I am using a experimental version right
so I should be able to type hello in
here and then we have a very very
bare-bones chat bot and the main thing
that this chat bot does is it asks you
the user what features you would like to
see in this chat bot and the reason why
I think that's an interesting way of
talking about it is because I don't know
what Pokemon people like like literally
no idea I played the game when I was 10
but what people can now do is they can
say well I want to learn the Team Rocket
theme song or something like that and
then says okay is there anything else I
can say yes simulations will also be
kind of nice no and then I get a couple
of these responses but the nice thing is
is that while that's happening yep
here's the conversation I just had so
this allows me to do some user tests
actually get this out there and have
people interact and play with it and the
nice thing about this rasa X instance is
that everything that I label there's a
nice little git link so I can click a
button that will update the get surfer
on github and and I also can train from
here and we like to think that this is
sort of from user interface and
maintainability perspective probably
something that you want to get started
with after you've actually done
everything on your laptop if you want to
get anywhere near production there's the
first thing that you should probably
install
so that's the whole demo that I had in
mind at least so I hope people sort of
look at browser X and go alright if I if
I want to do something in production
this rasa X is something I should keep
in mind because I do think this labeling
and keeping the data quality high that's
super important but until then I hope
that I have given people a nice
introduction on what we think are good
building blocks for making
conversational instances and in sort of
apps what what I think is nice about
this approach is that we have this nice
little middle road between high tech
algorithms but still some constraints
such that the algorithm doesn't derail
into something that we don't want it to
so that is something that I think is
going to be really valuable if you want
to do this stuff actually in production
and then I people are interested
definitely go to the get up thing and
add like some some intents maybe or like
maybe some extra examples it should be
relatively easy for you to do so but I
think watching other people merge that
p.r might be a little bit boring so
probably now is a good time to do
questions instead thank you so much
listen I have a question right away
speaking about building blocks yes we've
seen it's a bit of a process to get the
right behavior into your chatbot you
need to do a bit of engineering but
hopefully everyone will now use Raza and
start building better and better models
and there will be a model that's pretty
good as a small talk and chitchat
and if I want that behavior plus some
other behavior plus some custom behavior
that I built is there an easy way to
like combine behaviors abilities from
chat pods so in an extreme case you
could say oh we have one action server
and that decides whether or not like
extreme scenario let's say you have
multi language
we're German in English let's say those
are the two things we need to have for
this banking app you could take this
super extreme route and say oh you know
what I'm gonna have one action server
that's going to determine from there on
which of these two rouser instances
you're going to
talk to and that's something that we can
build out that way like the the the
thing here is is because it's all Python
we part of that responsibility lies with
you like you have to seriously think how
am I gonna maintain this the main thing
that we try to do is come up with stable
building blocks such that a lot of use
cases are properly covered so I'm just
gonna keep on with the multi-language
use case but I think it's interesting to
most people so one of the things that we
allow is we allow you to use
multi-language multilingual word
embeddings like Bertie have a couple of
multi-language versions of that but but
there is whole notion of conversational
design that I do want to admit is still
an unsolved problem this is all
relatively new stuff so we are trying
our best to learn it quickly as possible
and come up to like good practices but I
have to be honest here like we also
learn a lot from our clients like they
have datasets that we don't have access
to so the lessons that they learn we
know we have to get it in and then that
sense we're still learning as we're
going along we'd like to think we've got
a couple of good habits but for example
multi-language chat bolts that
definitely still work progress we're not
done there and the way I'm not yet at
the point where I can say okay give me
this small talk ability and then give me
the Pokemon ability and I just plug into
the other into and it's still my job to
integrate everything to some extent we
we like the thing that that's where the
data sets will help you because again we
the models that we make are this finds
to be really general and he gets yes
pretty state-of-the-art results and
that's once we think that for small talk
datasets are probably going to be more
effective than anything else just like
to thank you again if we're lucky it's a
matter of merging the datasets
[Music]
pretty much yeah well so you still need
to map that to actions and intense and
whatnot but let me the example FAQ but
that's a relatively standard thing
because it's it's pretty much in action
tent action there's no other sequence of
actions that you have to follow strictly
so we have a couple of these demo boss
said you can't go ahead and
just put if copy and then just your own
data set and for chitchat in particular
you have a little bit for data sets you
can also just go ahead and copy but I do
fundamentally think that a large chunk
of making general that bots is just
having the mineral data sets oh
definitely a ball on our scientist to
have like a standardized data set for
chitchat and German chitchat in Dutch it
in whatever and then by giving you the
data set you should already cover the
ground a bit they're questions that they
want to take them directly from the chat
why should I read them to you this I
think I think I could take this one
could you show a bit more about Raza X
how would you take a demo conversation I
used for training so super quick demo
and I should I should mention here this
is not the most recent version a more
recent version of Raja X also has like a
keyboard shortcuts that I can't demo
right now but if I were to go to L your
training LS where is Pikachu and if
that's that someone said that as a the
things that will suggest feature intents
and I want to learn a cats and ng
simulations and I want to learn a team
rocket's theme song these are some of my
responses but I think other people saw
mentioned that and the models is hey
that's a suggest feature and I can say
yeah that's that correct
and then someone here says please tell
me a joke and the chat BOTS thought it
was goodbye I can say nope that's bad
and I can say that should have been a
joke yeah mark is correct now okay so
you do this
you you label a couple of things and
every time you do this there's gonna be
a new line appear in that Enel you end
the file that's something that's
happening under the hood well while
you're doing this and if I were then to
click this button a new model gets
trained and then I have this models tab
where I can select which of the models
is active so that's something you can
all do from here essentially all the
commands that we've done from the
command line we have also made a user
interface for that
with the idea that you know it we can
extend this where maybe you have
multiple people that can do labeling and
maybe we can say things like only when
two people agree do we actually put the
label on disk and these are features
that we are considering putting in this
and we think that having a tool like
this is going to make it easier if you
to maintain and update and keep your
model in the loop so to say definitely a
lot of work in progress if you get the
newest version you should get the
keyboard shortcuts but that's the flow
typically that you would get another way
of saying this is some of you might have
heard this tool called prodigy the the
Spacey people are the explosion AI there
they have this tool where you can also
do some labeling and this is in a way
like prodigy but we like the thing that
this is specialized towards the digital
assistant chatbot use case but that's
why we see this going that for chat
bosses is something that's going to be
super specialized and to that